Here's everything my toddlers eat in a day.
Obviously, not every day looks the same,
and I usually don't cook them any extra meals.
They eat whatever lucky and I are eating.
With that being said, for breakfast,
they had some apple compote with some pumpkin pancakes.
They love a good cup of tea in the morning,
so I made them some tea midway through,
and I got started on my pancake batter by combining some eggs,
pumpkin puree, milk,
vanilla, and maple syrup and pouring that into my dry ingredients.
Plated that with the apple compote we made and some maple syrup,
and they ended up having seconds.
A little later, they requested a snack,
so I cut up some salami, parmesan cheese,
pistachios, and some pomelo.
Since it was so gloomy and cold outside,
I decided to make a lentil soup with some fresh roasted garlic.
Focaccia had been rising for four hours before I popped it in the oven
and finished off my lentil soup by adding some kale to it.
Once the bread was done, I cut it up and it was time to plate.
There's nothing better than a lentil soup to me,
and the kids absolutely love it as well.
But like every meal,
it's always a hit or miss on whether they're gonna have it,
but today they did not. Big snackers,
so usually they don't have a snack between lunch and dinner.
We also tend to have dinner at 5:30 or 6 So tonight
I made something quick and simple,
which was just a coconut milk,
poached cod, sauteed my onions and chillies,
added my coconut milk, some soy sauce,
first sauce, and let my fish poach for about five to eight minutes
before adding some spring onion and some cilantro.
And then we were done. We plated up the rice,
plated up the fish with some of that coconut milk,
topped it with some lime. It didn't end up loving it,
but they still had a decent amount.